basically while all these Avengers are
flying around dealing with very big
things who's who's here taking care of
the little guy and that's what Peters
always been about that's what Peter
Parker's mission basically is and while
he's encountered the Avengers what would
be like if you were a kid who played an
instrument in high school and suddenly
the biggest rock musician in the whole
world calls you takes you to Europe you
actually hold your own and big concert
in Ajaccio hams Quebec new school set
against this extraordinary cinematic
universe what we always try to do at
marvel studios is we're building the
cinematic universe is look at the big
picture how can things relate across
movies and across years Avengers
infinity war is a culmination of the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe has
started in May of 2008 with release
fireman
[Music]
everybody awesome news so Kevin Feige
revealed what their plans are for
spider-man through infinity war in the
next spider-man film in phase four he's
basically the new Tony Stark so I'm
going to explain what's going on because
this is awesome there's a new round of
the Spider Man tickets giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so I can
listen to Kevin Feige talk for hours
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe you
hear and talk a little bit about how
spider-man fits in and why he's so
important that he's actually becoming
the new connective tissue that Tony
Stark is so when I say that spider-man
is becoming the new Iron Man he's not
literally becoming the new Iron Man he's
not going to take over starts company
Iron Man isn't going to go away a lot of
people have been making a big deal about
Avengers dying during infinity war
because Kevin Feige said it's going to
be the end of the road for some of the
big a-list Avengers meaning that they
won't resign their contracts and they're
not going to get a sequel like Captain
America for or Thor 4 but we'll dig into
that because they said a whole bunch of
stuff they're doing spider-man press
right now for that movie but people are
asking them about infinity war in phase
4 so that's how we know about all this
stuff this is basically Robert Downey
jr. trying to duck the question about
passing the baton to spider-man and this
gives you an idea of how important
spider-man is for their plans going
forward into phase 4
Feige described the next spider-man
sequel as being like Civil War - that's
how big it is and how big it's going to
change the Marvel Universe if you didn't
think that infinity war and Avengers 4
would change the Marvel Universe what
happens is things are presented to me
that are really well thought out by
folks who have been doing this correctly
for a long time and I kind of just like
I don't like check you know and then
attempt to take the credit in press
conferences so I'm holding this whole
thing together yes
whatever I've been sent me retired since
again the first weekend that one open
you get inflated and then you think oh
my god I've created everything this
that's going my way and then things
happen where you go alright there's a
little evidence to the contrary and at
this point you go back to you
just like I'm you know I'm it's nice to
be on this call sheet but so as you can
see I've changed dramatically and I'm an
extremely humble individual so as you
can see Robert Downey jr. has no idea
what's going on he literally just signs
his name when they give him a call and
say hey we need you for a movie so
what's happening is is they're cycling
back the a-list Avengers in they're
cycling up people like Spider Man
because of that Kevin Feige promo that I
attached at the beginning of this video
if you need to rewind and watch it where
he says that spider-man is the person
who brings this to ground level and
helps keep it relatable he's actually
the reason why you probably won't see
defenders in the big Avengers movies
anytime soon so blame spider-man for
that if you want more TV crossover
because that's what the defenders would
be they'd be the ground-level heroes
looking up at all this crazy battles
happening in trying to relate to it as
average people like a couple of us have
superpowers but we're not really the
gods that people like Thor and Hulk are
so even though he's an a-list Avenger
he's sort of the kid that's watching
this all unfold and he's going to be the
connective tissue between all the phase
four movies meaning Z you might see him
pop up in other people's movies to like
think about how cool it would be to see
him crossover with Captain Marvel or
with ant-man for that matter a lot of
people like just crazy team ups that's
all we want to see from phase four and
that's the promise of it being super
different you have characters like
Doctor Strange that won't get their
sequel till phase four even though
they're still going to be doing
straight-up sequels like there will be a
Guardians three you're not going to see
six Iron Man movies they've already
confirmed that the next spider-man movie
will feature an a-list Avenger it's not
going to be Tony Stark I've already
talked a little bit about this but it's
probably going to be Captain America or
the Hulk or even Captain Marvel but I
don't think it's going to be her but
when they call Spider Man to Civil War
two that doesn't mean they're going to
be stuffing as many characters in it is
not going to be quite as crazy as the
actual Civil War movie was there just be
a lot more Marvel stuff going on in the
background helping it connect to the
other phase four movies but we can't
really talk about actual villains there
are things that they set up during
spider-man homecoming once we do spoiler
videos then we can talk about actual
characters you may have heard about some
of the secret cast that they kept under
their hat for a while please don't post
spoilers in the comments if you have
seen the
but you guys can let me know like you
see Iron Man popping up in all the phase
1 movies talking to the other Avengers
bringing them together for infinity war
how do you feel about Spider Man being
used is the connective tissue for all
the other movies going forward after
infinity war it just feels like a really
easy way for them to keep it relatable
but at the same time doing all the crazy
stuff like you see really crazy stuff in
the guardians of the galaxy movies
imagine Peter Parker crossing over and
going into outer space that is the
promise of some of these big Avengers
films they also confirmed that just like
the transition from Civil War to Spider
Man homecoming the timeline will be the
same from the fourth Avengers film to
Spider Man homecoming 2 they don't have
an official name for the movie it'll be
called spider-man something something
they're not going to call it spider-man
2 it'll be 2 months after the end of
Avengers 4 and it'll be just like
spider-man's next retreat with the
Avengers like you've seen in the
spider-man trailers when's our next
retreat that'll be what these next two
Avengers films are for Peter Parker so
that'll be a summer vacation then he'll
have to come back and be a kid who's a
junior in high school they did confirm
that it would be his junior year meaning
that the next spider-man movie after
that will be his senior year so he will
be in high school for the next three
movies beyond that we'll see what they
decide to do but Tom Holland is
committed to the character he wants to
do the robert downey junior 10 plus year
thing where you just stick around for
everybody else's movie even if you're
not going to do another spin-off but i
think we all know that sony really loves
that spider-man cash-cow so they're
going to want to keep making spider-man
films as long as possible
in addition to all the spider burst
stuff that they have with the venom film
silver sable black cat all the crazy
stuff they're planning for those are you
asking about the actual phase 4 movies
they've confirmed spider-man 2 whatever
it's going to be called will be the
first thing after Avengers 4 then we're
going to get guardians 3 and then they
don't have any more movies on the
schedule but they have said in the past
that we would see another Doctor Strange
movie that'll be phase 4 I think they
just haven't figured out what the movie
is going to be in Kevin Feige did say
that a lot of the titles for the phase 4
movies would be spoilers for infinity
war which just means crossover stuff so
they're talking about brand new
characters mixing the Avengers roster
because Peter Parker
be an Avenger by that time so it's not
like they want to give away the idea of
Captain Marvel becoming a bigger part of
the universe but if you've read the
comics and you know what happens during
infinity war then you have a pretty good
idea of how the universe is going to be
changing so just one more reason to keep
up with the comics believe all your
Marvel video requests in the comments
below I know you've been asking for a
spoilery spider-man review that embargo
is up on Thursday but I might wait till
the movie comes out because people
usually don't want spoilers until after
they see the movie but there'll be
Easter egg videos they'll be a lot more
spider-man Home Coming stuff coming in
the next couple of days but if there are
any special spider-man videos you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner completes journey please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll announce a new winner the
next time I post Marvel there'll be some
new Game of Thrones posting tomorrow and
there's that special Rick and Morty
event so I'll remind everyone as I post
new videos but you can click here for
that non spoilery spider-man homecoming
review and you can click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody say awesome I'll see
you guys tonight